[Music]
this story is about a secret restaurant
in Madrid oh yes
tapas no we are here for Chinese treats
whoa whoa how do we get down here again
buckle up
that's a long story it all started when
we got a tip saying Madrid had the
secret Chinese restaurant the most
authentic food ever but very hard to
find let's go there was no email no
proper address all reviews pointed to a
mysterious underground location we
called a one number available no
response
oh what a shame no wait we didn't give
up that easily
we got a friend in Madrid to get to the
bottom of it and she got us the right
directions good thinking I got it I got
it
there are no signs so follow these steps
we got to Madrid and followed the very
detailed instructions take notes people
go to Plaza spying our truck get to the
southeast corner check find the parking
lot entrance go down the stairs double
check
oh look Assad's restaurant remember
there are no signs oh yeah forgot go
down more stairs go through the corridor
welcome it well oh wait I think that's
it that's how you find cafeteria you
lungs ooh better known as the salsa
everyone meets yuzu and Lou fangs or mr.
Fawlty
or my ECG in these twos are some of the
most genuine Chinese food in Spain that
looks so good suddenly a woman would
hear the Halloween Cynthia La Mina said
the video to these delicacies are not
just your average Chinese dumplings
they're from the couple's hometown Xin
Jiang in the surrounding province
Zhejiang in southeastern China it's
actually where the majority of Madrid's
Chinese population is from or Missy
what's that warm ethnicity
so you want me to chant Cathy idea
Holika general material to her and she
wants a lot what you can see Wow
like really like it for a restaurant I
was this hard to find it seems like this
place never stops going it's already
deep inside totally apparently you gotta
tell us who does your marketing go on oh
man you know ideal way or make you mayor
thing we have aa come on May what about
one for us hey we'll take that as a
maybe
ah that was totally worth the trouble
please can we start filming now I am
really hungry one of the Circosta
realistic Adele courageous it is okay
you know Cheryl yankin Yaya Satan
constant a Yvonne Olsen and oh come on
raise yes show me agua de por que pagar
bayaud que cuando nombre confía en
Christo
enough adrenaline yamanami chef de vente
cinco de vacas - en nuestra cattigan
silver details on us your numbers are
ample salagadoola
rahabaan' or uyama your mucho
north to the other I get the tuna so you
love another tenemos que salir para que
les love clusters tengu mati stereo
castle entrada nests a cupola illa
critical ro con una una cadena tagging
or halal Medusa no Kiribati another
you to the Royal Society was from a
cousin yes impulsively
can you tell me like an Italian vida por
que que DiMucci shivakasi well
appearance a Content module they stuck
at adult cuando yo era question on the
column on TV - oh no no shell on the you
and I say sensical really really
Ariba gustaría dimensional and Estacada
they're so important a mommy
[Music]
[Music]
for a castle straight out of a fairy
tale look no further than the alcázar of
Segovia located in central Spain the
alcázar of Segovia is one of the
country's most visited and distinctive
landmarks built in the 12th century the
Alcazar has served many functions over
the years a fortress a royal palace a
state prison an Artillery College and
most recently a museum and military
archive however its most famous function
could arguably be that it served as an
inspiration in some of the most iconic
Disney films the similarities between
Segovia and Cinderella can be found in
the building's brick facade turrets and
location perched high above the
neighbouring countryside while Disney
also went on to reproduce Segovia as the
Queen's castle and Snow White with it
appearing in the film and it's almost
exact form if you can make it up more
than a hundred and fifty stairs to the
top of the tower you will be rewarded
with stunning views fit for a queen
[Music]
as a result another Allah Porter's
Jeremy shada veto anything controversial
don't see enter no in Tetris annular
film editor 120 Romanticism la barrera
Lenny Quintana Renta Estados apparently
was como entirely new postulant historia
Mohammed will have a sentence Alvarez 20
restaurant restaurant a boudin una las
cosas más importantes restaurant al or
no La Hoya's a la hora con o el or no
nausea paga the attend or siento noventa
it resolution repeated or siento no meat
eaters a new new Kashia paga de
Monterrey local opera noche yes our
Paula manana a special mode people in
Casa Baba I am and all my specialities
in criminal and plateau stereo the
raucous eyes and coaching coaching us
apathy al elahh PL esta muy caliente on
Lana and FINA she'll adult emote okay
because Lapierre suena Carlos and
paternal restaurant 817 Wado conscious a
relatively simple persona Shasta mentee
Walt a one-goal Ella well objection ago
Tina in senior loco Janeiro's PSoC do
lateral film and she knows it is
nosotros nosotras nasaw to remember
enjoy Sun Plateau certificado
totally the Senado communitas reversible
cochinillo vu de patatas interpreter
kamal case a Bunga cool aesthetic to
nollie flute are yourself elitism
rakia quarantine Angeles Chronicles
George esto como FFF available
respondent Amanda realest realest Iraq
Camila's que no se da la la receta until
was a machinist Iquitos fa la la receta
superior on drama do a para mojito
She'arim take on King Ghidorah que te
amo mucho erotic the main difficulties
of working with any vulnerable or
fragile work of cultural heritage is the
respect you have to have for that object
technology is at a point right now where
we can record the surface of an object
down to fractions of a millimeter and
it's through this kind of understanding
that allows you to communicate across
time and across cultures
[Music]
the task of heritage protection and
preservation is a real challenge
the mission of factum foundation is to
record cultural heritage so in the event
that there's a disaster or an accident
we have the data to know what was there
exactly as it is we're pioneering a
number of methods to return that
information into the physical world
we're doing CNC milling we're doing 3d
printing but we're trying to go beyond
that a facsimile of the Borg are in each
Apple the facsimile of the tomb of
Tutankhamen in the Valley of the Kings
an exact facsimile of Vera nasals
wedding at Cana
[Music]
[Applause]
the biggest project that's going on at
the moment is an exact facsimile of the
tomb of Seti the first which will be
given to the people of Egypt as soon as
it's finished two hundred years ago the
concern was not one of preservation the
concern was one of Indiana Jones and
discovery and excitement and cultural
acquisitions the tombs in the Valley of
the Kings lasted successfully for three
thousand three and a half thousand years
but since they've been visited they
start to decline and decay rapidly
I think the facsimile is opening up a
whole new level of possibility for
display preservation conservation
restoration communication dissemination
of what's important about these objects
if only we can preserve it like it is
and document it and hand it on to future
generations then there's hope the
mesquita has always been a spiritual
place but has not always been occupied
by the same religion nowhere else in the
world will you find a cathedral built
inside the walls of a mosque
originally the site of a temple to the
Roman god Janus the mesquita was built
as a mosque after Cordoba came under
Moorish rule in the late 7th century
then in 1236 the city of Cordoba came
under Christian rule and the mesquita
was converted to a church four centuries
later a cathedral was constructed in its
center and it became a home for the
town's Roman Catholics while the
cathedral is an example of classic
Catholic Baroque architecture the
majority of the mosquitoes construction
is a result of the work of Islamic
architects features like 856 columns and
symmetrical arches give the illusion of
infinite space these elements are
examples of why the mesquita is
considered one of the greatest
accomplishments in Islamic architecture
in the world today it is a unesco world
heritage site over a million people
visit every year and after all its
history it is now seen as a site of
religious significance to both Catholics
and Muslims
you
you
[Music]